parents you know about it captivated
imaginations apparently the schedule of
a lot of young people young adults right
it's called fortnight battle ranges
learning about well no no but this is
long as that penomet a year now but it's
gaining it's gaining prominence and
here's the danger a hundred and twenty
five million users around the world it's
free on multiple platforms it's
basically a Hunger Games in a cartoon
format people have to kill each other
the island they're on shrinks and if you
have to be the last man standing when
it's over I know kids at colleges
playing this in middle school here's the
problem gonna start playing kids are
addicted to this now 60 minutes in
Australia just did a piece on a little
boy
Logan Ford he's 14 years old he has not
left the house in two years he has
bitten his mother given her a concussion
and popped her in the face when she
tried to take the game console for it
sounds like here he is being interviewed
watch this okay by day Logan can be
found in the same spot playing the same
game over and over again
it was my choice I'm totally playing
about 14 hours a fortnight and similar
video games have been Logan's sole
obsession for the past two years at the
expense of almost everything else when
did you last write a book you see this
kind of gaming for this player this type
of play the World Health Organization
describes it as a gamer addiction it
leads to aggressive behavior bad
relationships with those around you
including your parents and you see it
there
you heard the bit about the book they've
done some research on the social media
replacing books we'll put this on the
screen in the 1970s 60% of high
schoolers were reading books today 16%
or less now you know I've devoted a big
part of my life to literacy writing for
kids I have a big announcement I want
kids to read I love that they're reading
my books I'm thrilled tonight to reveal
the first time for the first time the
cover of the third installment of my
will Wilder series for kids of all ages
it's called will Wilder the amulet of
power it premieres this February from
Random House it's available for
pre-order now at will Wilder books calm
and all retail and I didn't charge you
for the sketch I really got that you did
a lovely job the purple was I trying to
make it like the Cowardly Lion in The
Wizard of Oz but I didn't quite capture
I'm going to try not to write you in as
the villain of this book oh thanks well
I want to do that by the way I think
there's a problem when you bite your
mother that might be the when biting or
throwing of objects is involved at your
parents you have a problem none of my
will Wilder readers hit their mothers
when they can't want to know why my kids
don't play video games because of that
that they don't have computers to screen
that I think that our imaginations are
stuck I made a book it's a much better
way and it's a way to bring the family
look I have a problem with my phones you
know that I know much we I don't guess
what and I don't have my phone with me